let's go oh I don't know let's go to our
friend Eduardo from Brazil
hey David hey how are you um
I'm good how are you doing uh mesel Tov
on Argentina by the way thank you very
very exciting
yeah very exciting uh so I have a one
question for you sure uh we're about to
go to transfer power here in Brazil to
the president on the first yes uh
Tallulah and uh
but some things always been bothering me
like uh
before you know the sort of denying of
elections results has always been kind
of a a third world country kind of fair
you know and uh
and then Trump kind of pulled that into
his Playbook uh for you with a big lie
and everything
um so I guess my question to you is uh
did Trump kind of legitimize that for
like develop like like for like First
World countries or is it just becoming
kind of this oroboros where they just
kind of like creating their own Playbook
according to
you know sort of what usually happened
in sort of underdeveloped countries no I
think Trump absolutely
legitimized questioning the election
results whereas you're right I mean you
know to say that it was the sort of
baileywick of third world countries
maybe it's sort of like to more accurate
to say or maybe more precise that
questioning election results
really just makes your country look bad
more than anything else but Trump
figured out a way to do it where at
least among his followers because he
kind of couched it as well it was
Democrats running elections and when it
was Republicans running elections it was
the Democrats doing the voter fraud and
and or it was Democratic judges but when
it was Trump appointed judges then it
was like the county commissioner you
know what it was just like a special
pleading no matter what he figured out a
way to do it where his followers can say
with a straight face we believe it was
rigged with out realizing what that
would suggest about the United States
and I do think that it's being copied in
other countries as you're pointed at
pointing out
it's uh it's kind of concerning because
you know
um the fact that it's I mean I I hate to
say it but it's kind of successful in in
some ways should perform Yeah by using
it like a lot of people you know do the
cult of personality or like the men can
do no wrong so if he says something it's
gospel you know now in Brazil are the
bolsonaro supporters saying it was
stolen from him he really won
well technically he conceded but his
followers haven't like I mean I I've
I've been in Brazil for about two weeks
now yeah and uh yeah it it's there's a
very sort of uneasy feeling uh for
January 1st because there are still
picket lines they still
come out you know with with the shirt
like uh it's it's almost confusing
because every time you see like a car
with the Brazilian flag sticking out you
that automatically goes that that's a
like a bolsonaro follower yeah but it's
confusing with the World Cup because you
don't know if it's a World Cup kind of
like flag but he's Brazil left the World
Cup yeah so the the
there is a little feeling of an ease
here uh see seeing what happens because
a lot of people haven't accepted it even
though he has conceded understand
understand yeah I mean listen I I don't
know about in other countries but I
think in the U.S Republicans saying if
they lost that it was rigged is going to
be with us for at least another election
cycle
no it's the new normal which is is
worrisome for me because uh it's it's
become kind of part of the Playbook and
uh yeah I just wanted to run it by it
because it's like the the
legitimization of of
um you know denying an election result
and unfortunately kind of Fairly
successfully done by Trump
um is is scary because it's just kind of
like again crosses the Rubicon that I
don't think it will be hard to come back
from it's extremely scary you're
absolutely right Eduardo thank you for
the call
thank you David take care all right
there goes Eduardo from Brazil